thank you everyone welcome to this
meeting of cabinet on the 18th of july
and we are joined by
councillor nigel rock
uh substituting for councillor junard
and councillor andy crump uh who's
chairman of osa they're joining us
online
um
which is a dispensation because of the
heat the rest of us have to be here
because we have to be physically present
if we make decisions
so with that apologies for absence and
none later thank you disclosures of
interest does anyone have any
disclosures of interest on items on the
agenda
i'll take
councillor pemberton uh yeah thank you
leader and i think this is one that is
uh shared by all members of cabinet i've
received correspondence in relation to
uh item 15 and item 17
from wells born airfield i think we've
probably all had
the same correspondence
i certainly have so i would assume you
were absolutely right council of
pemberton
that everyone has
uh
councillor barker
i've got a hybrid car
council trump your hybrid car i've got a
funny electric hang on
counselor rock
we have a real sound problem chairman we
we we've we have a sound problem we're
getting
can you not hear at all can i just check
remotely can you you've got no no audio
dave albert can you hear i can hear
everything fine so um no problems at all
so i don't know whether it's something
councillor rocks send
councillor crump yeah i can hear how can
he even hear councillor pemberton
i can hear
no nigel can i can you can you leave and
come back in all right
chairman on the question of um
declaration of interest about ev cars
um i think we've given legal advice to
councillor rock specifically who asked
that same question
and we felt that the the connection
wasn't approximate enough to actually
constitute even the raising of the item
as an issue under item
two
seems to make a remarkable amount of
sense mr grafton
i will just wait for a couple of minutes
for councillor rock to
sign in again
welcome back nigel ah
okay that seems to be working
good i could hit i could hear everything
three times spaced by about four seconds
so um
[Laughter]
right i think you just got to interest
and i think you were saying uh people
were saying the same as i have i've got
an electric car so um i want to declare
the same interest what i think you were
dealing with
we've just been told by the monitoring
officer that the connection between any
papers we might consider and electric
vehicles is uh exceedingly distant so we
don't need actually declare those as
interests is that a fair summary mr
grafton yes exactly chairman thank you
uh item three on the agenda minutes
are there any uh issues on the minutes
or can i sign these after the meeting is
a to unfair reflection of the meeting
i was fine thank you
so
moving on then
item four south warwickshire electric
vehicle ev infrastructure strategy
uh
this i would say is for noting and
recommendation one
so
councillor shenton do you wish to
introduce this
thank you lady but i'll let dave uh
introduce this one mr barber over to you
thank you yes as as you say chair uh
this is really asking you to note the
work that cemex have done in
the report that's attached to appendix
one
and to agree that we
develop a joint strategy and procurement
exercise with warwick district council
to look at bringing in
ev charging infrastructure
across south warwickshire i think one
point i would make from the um
fro from the
uh report that sun at work the cenex
have done is that they have in the
report uh looked at
um 10 car parks only clearly there are
significantly more car parks than that
across south warwickshire those 10 car
parks i think we need to
understand as being
examples and we would be able to
extrapolate the information we've got
from those 10 car parks to other
locations so
for instance where there are car parks
um in some of the um
rural areas uh stratford district that
haven't been specifically picked up in
this report it doesn't mean that they
will be excluded from the strategy that
we'll be bringing forward
in the report in quarter three
thank you mr barber i have councillor
cargill and then councillor shenton
thank you leader um this is one today i
believe um thank you very thorough
report very comprehensive
uh
question though
with my other hat on as a chairman of
the a46 partnership working very closely
with midlands connect
i couldn't spot in here if you've if
they've been consulted at any time
i'm fairly certain they haven't
consulted
a 46 partnership but we are discussing
exactly this
topic and it feels that we should be
certainly widening the the scope a
little bit to make sure that we've got
all of the interested parties talking
do you have any comments on that please
mr barber uh they they haven't been
consulted on this the intention of this
report was to look at just the
district council's uh own facilities
such as car parks um it doesn't exclude
it doesn't cover the need for
other ev charging infrastructure for
instance the
what the infrastructure the private
sector might provide adjacent to the
motorway or the a46 as a trunk road or
indeed on street um
parking that the county council might
provide uh we are coordinating with the
county council quite carefully in the in
bringing forward these proposals to
ensure that they dovetail but no
midlands connect haven't been consulted
at this point
chairman if i may just say it's not a
simple
down the road motorway or a46 it's all
feeding off them and so it is actually
part of this infrastructure it's just
something that we do need to to ensure
that we haven't missed a trick here
somewhere or we're overlapping
can you take that point on please mr
barber
noted we can pick that up during the
next stage
thank you thank you leader um it's just
to uh to say that the climate change
panel
um discussed this paper at its last
meeting and the climate change panel
were happy with the paper
and just to
also point out that um this is really
setting the tone for what we want to do
going forward we need to push ahead on
bringing in the ev infrastructure when
you compare us to places like norway
norway are well ahead of us because
they've used things like the north sea
oil receipts obviously to finance this
we have we have some way to go we the
the scale of uh increase
uh is pretty phenomenal that we we need
to achieve uh over the next few years up
to 2030 so this is really uh
the start of pushing ahead with our own
strategy but dovetailing in with
as dave said uh dave father says it
dovetailing him with county on this
thank you council of shenton i believe
councillor crump you wish to comment
i don't mind which order it goes in andy
um
age before
does
beauty
mean i've got to go before you then
yes
councillor crumb
followed by councillor rock
um yeah just obviously we just i'm on
the climate change panel and we also
discussed this that um
on s on friday night i afford this for
this on to you uh uh chairman um
i would just welcome the work carried
out by on the software
electric vehicle and just infrastructure
charging etc and it was welcomed the use
of the same consultant who did the
county's on street work to do our street
work obviously it made sense and
the wcc contribution was welcome
and a good example of public co-op
operation
we recommend that the cabinet agrees to
the joint strategy and procurement
exercise with wdc
and ons note the various procurement
models open to both councils
and finally work needs to be done to
ensure the quality of access is insured
particularly in the more rural areas
where sites are not necessarily
commercially attractive
and investigating the levi fund for
rural areas should be done as well as
potentially joint bidding for grants
so that's a combination of the
information from the joint from the
client panel on what was discussed in
detail
um and i've also been in liaison with uh
mr folk skinner from uh wdc um in dave's
absence
on this as well so
um it was welcomed and divided in detail
at
ons thank you
thank you councilman crump councillor
rock
thank you chairman i
agree with it everything's said i
very much welcome the paper and the
comments that have been made uh just
one thing i would add in the the issue
of rurality
um i can shed a bit more light onto that
when we look at stratfor district
um we've got this wide royal air and i
think uh one of the things that um wants
to be considered going forward is what
we can do in the villages
and uh
i think you'll probably be aware that
knapton village hall has recently put
two
charging points in
um
and that
some of the forecasts that are contained
in that report seem to be somewhat
pessimistic about usage
because i've got figures from the
the two points that have gone in upton
village or they've only been in two
weeks and they've already been used for
127 hours charging so it would seem that
obviously it's hardly a representative
staff statistically but i think we do
need to make sure
that we think more widely across our
rural district how we do that as we go
forward um but there are other issues to
do with our mobile phone coverage which
is uh obviously a key thing and the way
it works at the moment turn but um
as it's already been considered by the
climate change panel i won't i won't
waste the uh
cabinet's timing going over the old
ground again but i think we're
everybody's welcoming this so um
i think we will want to be involved in
it thank you very much
thank you councillor rock
uh
councillor harvey
thank you leader
following on nigel's point um
one of the facts that the paper produces
is that there are over 3 600
existing users of an ev vehicle in in
stratford and warwick
um given that this is an exercise in in
trying to determine how many publicly
available
charging points should be made available
and where they should be located
i would have thought that it would have
been interesting at least
to
use that 3600 population as a guinea pig
so to speak to find out exactly how they
currently charge their vehicles
because if you find that all three
thousand six hundred plus charge their
vehicles at home
you may conclude that there's a very
limited demand
for
publicly available charging points
equally if they were to
charge their vehicles at work
you'd get a different answer equally if
they were to charge their vehicles at
the existing
existing publicly available charging
points you get a different answer it
strikes me that the experience and
practice of those existing drivers is
could be an interesting and informative
information base to inform this policy
i don't see and i may have missed it but
i don't see that that as a potential
source of information has been tapped so
my first question is have i got it wrong
have i missed something
does mr barber agree that would be a
useful source of additional information
and my second is it's not a question
it's simply a point i hear what is said
about the 10 sample
car parks
that's fine provided that's all they are
ten samples that these are not just
because they have appeared in print in
this report that they become
established locations
and therefore and and then additional
locations are added on as far as
shipstand is concerned telegraph street
the town council has discussed and it is
not the preferred site so i i want a
reassurance if i can have it that these
are indicative sites for the purpose of
this exercise and that the town council
will be consulted before any firm
decisions are taken and that applies not
only to shipstand but other towns and
locations that are affected thank you
thank you councillor harvey councillor
shenton
yeah i mean the paper it is indicative
these are not definite sites they were
just chosen for the for the purposes of
the paper
i mean we have a a a problem generally
with ev charges in rural areas we need
to put more in rural areas
the the major
suppliers like bp charge point and these
sort of numbers they're only interested
in cherry picking so this this is really
just setting the tone of what we're
going to do what we're going to look at
it's not it's not set in stone as such
it's it really is a
a a positioning paper run more than
anything else
before i bring councillor barker in
mr barber do you just want to
deal with council harvey's other points
please
oh i'm happy to sorry can can you hear
me okay oh yes i think i had a slight um
technical breakdown there but yeah the
um the report is actually based on um
some work that cenex did for
warwickshire county council last year um
and that report draws on quite a lot of
data um
send census data and ons data about um
charging usage um in various different
kinds of geographical location
uh and in different circumstances such
as whether people have um
you know that their off street parking
associated with their house and and so
on um and
uh what it then does is take that data
and map it against the existing
locations of um electric vehicle
charging infrastructure to reach a
viewers to to
where and how much and what type of
additional infrastructure is actually
needed um so to directly answer the
question that's been raised um no we
haven't tapped into the uh
any direct conversations with existing
local users but there is a lot of
information about usage habits that the
report draws on
council harvard do you want to come back
on that i do if i can um
i hear the answer i'm
i'm grateful for the clarity of the
answer is no
um
i would caution however that where
you're building a policy based upon
national average
data
over the whole country it may not be a
very good basis when you're talking
about a rural district council area like
stratford
a fair point i think councillor harvey
and i'm sure that will be taken on board
councillor barker
um that's kind of what i want to
sock home a bit harder that
when it's done as an average over
places that are considered to be towns
that are bigger towns and the more one
that both
councillor harvey and i represent um
so many more moving parts are involved
that this
i don't think it i i don't think it's
even touching it um because we've
already been through this with the
county
um i and i'm grateful that that we're
working together now but we've been
around this once
um the car park that is suggested in
this paper doesn't have
sufficient infrastructure to support it
which was discovered when we did the
county work where county wanted it
wanted our ev charges in shipston were
utterly inappropriate um as has been
proved councillor harvey would pick up
because we've got the same number of
spaces at the moment removed because
there is scaffolding up and shipston is
an absolute nightmare we know where we
want the damn things
nobody asks us
and once it gets put in black and white
i don't care that this is only a
suggestion
it's a much harder suggestion than it is
when we just talk about it um and i
don't think it's beyond the wit of man
to consult the town councils they're not
all
brilliant but you know they do have a
view and they do know their local patch
as do the local councillors and bearing
in mind that in shipston and i can't
speak for the other
smaller towns um we've been through this
once already it's irking me somewhat to
be going around it again
councillor brooklyn sorry
mr evan thank you very much
i i i think i think the point should
have been made that this is a piece of
evidence this is just a at this stage it
isn't the suggestion of where future
charging spaces will be taken into if
you've
heard a lot of comments around the the
the table this afternoon this is a piece
of evidence that will go towards
supporting that new strategy and yes i'm
sure when we start looking at localities
that the town and parish councils will
be consulted that particular point but
at this stage it's just a piece of
evidence for you to receive effectively
today as part pretty much what we do on
the local plan we see pieces of evidence
as we go and then that leads to
development of a future strategy i seem
to have incited rather than put down
you've over excited councillor barker on
that one because
when you mention the local plan i i
don't want to
talk about
reserve sites but
it's a similar sort of once it's in
writing you and i both know
not good
i think councillor harvey and councillor
barker have made
points that need to be recognised
councillor kettle
the other thing that we need to consider
is um the electrical supply capacity
um and it is all very well having
um charge points on every new housing
estate which we know is now an online
i'm pretty sure it's a planning
application
um for new properties to have a plug in
things
um it is no good having plug-in places
all over the county all over the
district rather if there isn't
sufficient electricity to actually
supply them so i think we need to take
into account in in the report
um the expect expected level of supply
and whether that supply is going to be
more or less than the demand
or enhanced demand from this this
proposal
thank you councillor kettle i would also
just go back to
looking around my colleagues quite a
number of them come from quite large
settlements
uh i do not and therefore um i
absolutely underwrite what council
harvey and council parker have said in
some extents
but the bigger settlement is going to be
more attractive to commercial operators
the smaller settlements will not and
therefore we need to start at the bottom
end upwards rather than the top end
downwards otherwise we'll have exact
same thing we have with broadband
that every single
large settlement
um whatever it may be will be having
better and better facilities and once
again the rural settlements
will not and they will you will
exacerbate the considerable problem we
have between facilities provided to
urban especially rural dwellers
to that before i bring councillor
barkery
please um
in the in the paper i'm just struggling
to find it i mean we do talk about
uh and in the the just the cynics report
do talk about um rural and smaller areas
and socially deprived areas as well and
it's not all about
the henleys the main rural centers if
you like um it's definitely not that
because those will be served by the big
companies and maybe under license from
ourselves or or where we get
some kind of cut from it
this this is looking at
if you like the whole district not that
not the main rural centers and the paper
has got reference to the fact that we're
talking about those you mentioned uh
western power supply
on top of that i will say that the the
big issue when i went to uh western
power what some of the western power
conferences that they've held
has been the fact that
maybe local substations won't be able to
handle um the the the demand but those
can be upgraded now there is a cost to
that um and that will all be
if you like costed into the final paper
this is a
this positioning paper it's nothing more
than that understand councillor shenton
i think the points that are being raised
by councillors are
valid and i think they need to be taken
into account it is worth mentioning that
i've seen figures at the moment that
indicates some
54 billion needs to be spent on the grid
to bring it up to speed which is quite a
significant amount of money but without
the electricity you can't have charging
points councillor barker do you wish to
come in
two things
to reassure councillor kettle that there
is funding out there there are people
who will put up these smaller scale ones
plus um an example in stratnam foss
in my ward is where they put a
double-headed charging point up that on
the parish hall
and they've also had funding for their
solar panels so it
there are ways of doing this in the
rural patches that really do work and
obviously we need small scale nuclear
thank you councillor market i'm not sure
a small-scale nuclear is kind of within
the remit of this particular paper but
never mind
recommendations on page five
recommendations one and two our cabinet
happy with those recommendations
great thank you members of cabinet so
moving on item five long master
neighborhood development plan
pre-submission consultation responses
counselor pemberton
thank you chairman and leader uh members
the paper before you and the
recommendation um is in relation to long
marston's neighborhood development plan
uh firstly i'd like to thank the
longmarson neighborhood development
group for the work that they've done so
far and also to thank policy officers
for the work they've done in supporting
the group we're now at the regulation 14
pre-submission consultation stage
and the recommendation before you is
that the
schedule of uh significant comments made
by this authority at appendix one are
endorsed and submitted to long marston
parish council as the formal response
in order that they can work through that
to move to the next stage of their
neighbourhood development plan process i
have mr careford with me
to take any questions or any other
points
other than that i'm seeking uh
cabinet member support for the
recommendation as outlined on page 79 of
your papers
kelsey harvey
just to comment on
the neighborhood development plan itself
one fact which i took note of this is
another illustration of a neighborhood
development plan for a rural area where
96 of the population use a car three
percent use public transport
it it points to the fact that if you
haven't got a car living in a rural area
you have got a problem and the vast fast
vast vast majority of people who do live
in in long marston and similar locations
have to make use of cars
end of it's really important
thank you councillor harvey with that
sorry
with that uh this is a fairly routine
piece of business so can i ask cabinet
to agree the recommendation on page 79
thank you members of cabinets so moving
on
uh performance management framework
measures and monitoring arrangements
uh councillor jennings
hopefully not too confrontational this
one i think chairman um summary on this
is that the report represent presents uh
the proposed measures and monitoring
arrangements for 22.23 obviously it
should be noted that the merger pandemic
etc
had originally been undertaken in this
area and needs to be revisited but uh
i'm seeking support for the following
recommendations one to note delay on
agreeing council plan actions two to
approve the key performance indicators
and targets and three to approve the
monitoring arrangements set out in
paragraph three
thank you councillor jennings i have
councillor cargill then councillor rock
thank you so just a comment um
we have been
using
more graphical indicators of the
um statistics that presented but we
haven't got any on this particular one
am i
missing that
chairman if i
could if i could respond to that
absolutely for when we were reporting
the performance the actual performance
we're using the infographics that
melanie and the team have developed to
support that in a you know really visual
way what we're doing here is setting the
targets for the coming year so
we
that will be used but just not in this
report
thank you thank you mr buckland i now
have uh
councillor rock and then councillor
trump councillor rock
uh thank you chairman and just a
question on page 95
units of bed and breakfast accommodation
and uses temporary accommodation
not reported
and uh within
we have we don't have any sight of a
target at present i just wondered what
why we've got not reported in there
there's any comment available on that
place
uh mr purple do you want to come in on
that please
you chair um yes we've received those
targets since uh subsequent to the
report being published so i can tell you
that the the missing ones on housing uh
the bed and breakfast one is nil
uh homelessness is
sixty percent
home choice plus is eighty percent and
the
disabled facility grant is 210 days
if that helps
thank you mr perfil can we capture those
numbers in the minutes please
uh councillor crum
thank you chairman uh yes we discussed
this briefly
at the ons um
we think there's still possibly more
explanation in the performance
framework needs particularly for the
councillors
um
maybe some more narrative may be needed
to explain the variances mr platz was at
the meeting
uh to do with the home choice police
and he explained that some cancels
uh set the clock starting straight away
whereas others set the clock stated a
bit later on once they had asked for
information
so
we need to make sure whether targets are
still relevant and appropriate and
whether they need to be refined
and the other thing that we thought was
quite important was what's right they're
identifying areas where performance is
not being met um cancers and members of
the public need to acknowledge the
mental targets they're being met and
exceeded and passed that appreciation on
to the mem to officers who are carrying
out these services uh above and beyond
the target so um just a point of note
and a point for
for noting really particularly around uh
staff who are doing a great job thank
you
thank you councillor compand i think
your comments are well made and we have
been operating in a particular volatile
time council of shenton
yes thank you mr chairman uh it's uh
just a quick one um just to point out on
page 97
the percentage of household waste we've
already achieved that
we're doing less than 58 can we change
that to just greater than 58 i think
it's still an error in there
thank you
point melted council of shenton with
that the recommendations on page 89
are members of cabinet happy with those
recommendations
agreed thank you
moving on
uh resources portfolio counselor harvey
draft revenue altern report 2122.
thank you leader
the purpose of this paper is threefold
first to ask cabinet members to note the
draft financial results for last year
second to seek the cabinet's agreement
to the resultant variants being added to
the general fund reserves and third to
ask members of the cabinet to note the
amount to be added to the council's
earmarked reserves
in relation to the first purpose the
past financial year was again
predominated by the effects of the covid
19 pandemic
this led to higher costs in some areas
and significant shortfalls against
budget budget revenue
the key paragraph in the paper is
paragraph 1.4 which reports that in
contrast to the preceding year of 2020
2021 when the council incurred a net
deficit of 2.2 million pounds
the council is able to report a
favorable out turn of 22 000 pounds
after having prudently created the near
mark reserve of one million pounds to
meet the unanticipated impact of the
increase in the rate of inflation of
which we were all which we are all now
well aware and which we were not aware
at the prospect of the time the budget
was created and subsequently approved
table 1 itemizes the most significant
areas of variation from budget and
demonstrates the range of the council's
operations over which the management
team must exercise close financial
control
table 2 on pages 104 105
sets out the basis of the council's
general revenue reserves at the end of
march 2022
of eight and a half million pounds in
round terms
some items of intended expenditure could
not be undertaken during the year as
have been provided for in the approved
budget along with the unbudgeted income
received for specific projects it's
requested therefore that the sum of two
million three hundred and seventy
thousand six hundred and five pounds is
as itemized in table three on page 105
be set against the
2021-22 budget and be included in the
earmarked reserves to enable the items
of intended expenditure to be undertaken
in the current year
subject to any questions members of the
cabinet may have i ask that the
recommendations set out on page 101 be
approved
thank you
i see
no
questions
i was wrong councillor kettle
i made the point last year mr chairman
that the actual variance to budget
um
in a very very challenging year
was actually we were 133
um thousand pounds better off
in 2021
but we transferred three
and a quarter million in round figures
to reserves to give the 2.2 million
deficit the council harvey referred to
the actual performance
was fantastic
last year
and we commended i think mr buckland's
team
at this meeting 12 months ago for that
performance
um if we then look at this here
and this is a discussion we have had
before
um we are
heading for a net variance to budget of
about 2 million pounds
but is then transferring
um
a sum two zero five zero to reserves to
gives our net
favorable position on the revenue
accounts twenty two thousand
i really believe it is
important
that we we split
actual revenues and costs incurred by
this authority against budget
and what we post year-end decide to
transfer to reserves with that surplus
this year
or last year where we had a surplus but
we transferred more than that surplus
and therefore once again our last minute
congratulations to members of mr
buckland's team
for delivering a surplus against budget
of two million pounds enabling us to
transfer two million pounds and i'm
talking very round figures here
um to reserves
uh leaving us with the net favorable
position 22 000 it really is so
important to understand real against
bookkeeping
um transfers
thank you council of cattle uh i think
you are right and i think given the way
that things are going particularly with
inflation
we really are going to need the reserves
uh councillor rock
thank you chairman i i think probably
i'm i'm asking a similar question with
with less knowledge than the previous
speakers but um
uh um section 1.4 on page 101
on the 7th of march
and i don't want to be commodity here
but we predicted an unfavorable uh act
turn of
682 000
yet three weeks later
it was a favorable act turn of
a million because we've transferred a
million to reserves if i think i've got
that right so there's a difference of
1.7 million it seems a very
sudden
change in fortunes
have i misunderstood that
i think councillor rock and
i am sure mr burrow will correct me here
there are an awful lot of things that
only happen at the year end with central
government
funding
uh mr burrow could you comment on that
please
yes thank you chair um
you're correct we did receive income at
the end of the financial year
that
literally was untimely so we have to
carry that forward and put that into an
earmark reserve but i just the report
that's presented in early march is
actually prepared using the information
available around just after christmas
time
at that time and i'm just looking at the
uh variance explanation that's there we
were still
completely unaware of the refuse
collection costs as a result of the
essington fire
um so we were still budgeting for
potentially the full effect of what we
could have been exposing our
finances to in respect to that uh
service and and that's why that's a
difference of about 400 000
housing benefits yes there was a
year-end adjustment for
uh accounts that were outstanding that a
number of accounts had been actually
paid off during last year so we reduced
the bad debt provision by a hundred
thousand pounds so that improved that
service position as well
so there are a number of items like the
chairman says that are adjusted for at
the end of the financial year
but up until that point of time has at
the end of period
10
it's um
and that's what was used to report in
march
those were the best predictions that we
had at that time
so christmas came in march
indeed council ralph so with that uh our
members happy with the recommendations
on page 101
thank you so moving on then capital out
turns to say
we should record our thanks to mr
buckland's team
for
the
remarkable performances here again
i would agree councillor kettle and i'm
sure we'll capture that in the minutes
thank you
uh with that moving on uh
item eight capital out turn 20 21 22 in
capital slippage once again councillor
harvey
this is going to be tedious isn't it
with six papers to present
from your point of view
thank you leader the purpose of this
paper is twofold the first purpose is to
inform members of the amount of money
spent by the council on capital
expenditure items in the last accounting
period to the end of march
2022
this amounted in round terms to eight
million pounds rounded up as shown in
the third line of table one
i draw attention to paragraph one point
five which refers to section 106 and
seal funds
of this total capital expenditure the
total of section 106 and sil funds
uh spent in 2021-22
was 405 000 pounds the details for the
year ended 31st march 2022 are set out
in appendix 1.
appendix 2 on the other hand provides
details of the amounts and purposes for
which section 106 funds that total some
7.4 million pounds of which nine hundred
and fifteen thousand pounds had been
committed and a further six and a half
million pounds was yet to be committed
were held at the end of the financial
year
the second purpose of the paper is to
seek the cabinet's agreement to amounts
of capital expenditure that could not be
spent in 2122
to be carried forward to be available
for commitment in the current financial
year of 2223
these are referred to as items of
slippage and they amount to 13.9 million
pounds as summarized in table three
set out in paragraph 2.5
and accounted for by head of the
relevant functions in appendix 3.
brief details of the reasons supporting
significant items that are sought to be
carried forward are set out in
paragraphs
2.21 to 2.2
10. there are various reasons for each
of the amounts requested to be carried
forward which i'm sure mr burrell would
be happy to provide further explanation
if required
given current practices therefore i ask
members of the cabinet to accept the
recommendation that the capital budget
for 2022-23
be increased by 13
908
120 pounds for the reasons set out and
as recommended on page 117 of the paper
thank you leader
any questions any comments members of
cabinet
uh counselor rock
thank you chairman it's another small
point
uh i always like to keep trevor harvey
on his toes if i can
and on page 120 we have uh 20 000 pounds
set aside for
venture house improvements
uh whereas uh in the uh which is in mind
in the papers is there the a three
papers it says there's changes to the
building layout
to generate income to the control system
that's what it's for but uh
are we not closing venture house so why
are we spending the money
am i misunderstanding something there
i wonder if mr buckland on the question
of venture house would like to have a
word chairman through yeah this is
precisely the point that council rock is
talking about
there is no
so the budget that was approved by
council in february contained a savings
requirement on the venture house to make
it cost neutral and try and generate
more income from venture house so that
we can retain the service adventure
house so this 20 000 pounds is to
actually help achieve a cost neutral
position in relation to the ongoing
revenue costs venture house
thank you mr buckland
councillor kettle just fine for
clarification on page
well the first the big ones
appendix one
um
the slippage under joint head of assets
uh is greater than the budget remaining
i just couldn't could someone just gives
an explanation to us on that
sorry uh well appendix one
capital budget
um
i suppose it's page 123 it's immediately
after 242.
um
gross expenditure joint ahead of assets
the amended estimate of 865 the actual
spending of 618.
we've got budget remaining of 200 and
just short 250 000 but the slippage is
greater than that
what an interesting question councillor
kettle
cancer kettle i'm told that's a very
interesting question
[Laughter]
can we take it away
thank you
uh the recommendation on page 117 uh
subject to people uh
reviewing the question that council kept
last uh are we happy to accept the
recommendation on page 117
thank you
uh prudential indicators out turn 20
i'm sorry council barker is it my
imagination or is the air conditioning
gone off
is
it's hard to tell with me but it does
feel a tad warmer than it was
shut up right moving swiftly on then
given he's getting hotter
can i just respond to the question that
council the kettle raised um about the
slippage request from the jordan
harvards i don't know which page because
they're not numbered but but further on
in the package of big papers there is an
itemization of the expenditure and
income for each well the expenditure for
each of the individual elements within
the head of assets and the underspend is
462 058 on the planned maintenance
element of that overall budget that's
the element that's requested to be
slipped forward there is an overspend in
relation to the next steps accommodation
program with 237 000 well i believe that
to be funded in a different way so i i i
hear what you say in relation to the
slippage request in total seeming to be
larger than the overall underspend on
the account but actually it is all
related to the planned maintenance
program
and the other elements have been funded
elsewhere
i think it will be very useful to
actually capture that in the minutes
because
i think it was a very fair question to
actually ask
i picked a minute secretary sorry i pity
the minute secretary
you're absolutely right councillor
harvey i must desist prudential
indicators i'll turn 20 21 22.
councillor harvey
thank you
the council is required by the citra
credential code to set potential
indicators that ensure that its capital
investments plans are affordable proven
and sustainable
the purpose of this paper however is to
present the out-turn position for 21-22
in relation to the chosen credential
indicators
the paper sets out that the council
approved the 2122 budget that made
provision for the authority to borrow up
to 15.6 million pounds in relation to
the development of the material
recycling facility through the arms
length company in which it has a stake
3.1 million pounds in relation to the
council's leisure centers and finally
4.5 million pounds in connection with
the refuse vehicles as part of the
arrangements with the contract with
biffer
in the event that capital budget was not
drawn upon in 2122 because the council's
borrowing requirement
has been funded from internal resources
the need for the council to borrow
within its authorized limits has
therefore been deferred
the consequence of this would have been
in the past that rather than incurring
an interest charge on money borrowed the
council would have generated the
positive net revenue stream from its
financing costs
as indicated in paragraph 2.1.2
and explained in the subsequent
paragraph there was an adverse variance
of 51 000 pounds in the council return
on the funds that it held during the
year
this amount uh this amounted to 51 000
pounds and was attributable to
historically low interest rates to meet
the challenges of recovery from the
economic impact of the covid19 pandemic
market rates have subsequently increased
and are likely to increase further in
the very near future
the consequence of the agreed borrowing
of up to 15.6 million pounds not having
been drawn upon is recorded in the
variance of this amount reported in
paragraph 2.3.4
similarly paragraph 2.5.1
records that the council's capital
expenditure during the year was less
than provision had been made
this for a variety of reasons largely
beyond the council's control resulting
in 3.7 million pounds being carried
forward to 22 23.
unless there are any questions leader
i'd ask that members of the cabinet
agree to receive the report
thank you are there any questions
i'll take that as a no so the
recommendation on page 139 that the
report be received are members of kevin
happy to receive the report
great thank you so moving swiftly on
animal treasury management review 2122
once again councillor harvey repeated
thanks
this paper is presented because it forms
part of the monitoring process for which
members are responsible
it fulfills a requirement under the
cipher code of practice on treasury
management
the effect of sections two and three is
to illustrate that all of the council's
capital expenditure last year of 7.96
million pounds was financed either by
capital receipts
or by capital grants
or by revenue contributions
as shown in table 3 on page 146
the council did not borrow any funds
last year
section 4 shows that at the end of the
financial year the council had funds
under management of 49 million pounds
all of which was managed by aberdeen
sterling aberdeen standard limited
section 8 of the paper indicates that
aberdeen standard limited's performance
generated a gross return of nine
thousand pounds set against the budgeted
assumption of a hundred thousand pounds
when fees of sixty six thousand pounds
are taken into account the result was
that a net cost of seven thousand pounds
was incurred attributable in large
measure to the performance of ultra low
investment rates during the year under
review
the remainder of sections five and six
of the report reviewed the level of
interest rates over the review period
and those forecast over the next two
years
the broad messages from this information
are
one
at the time last year market
expectations were that the rate of
inflation as measured by the cpi would
rise by four percent
by the end of quarter four in 2021
whilst financial markets were expecting
bank rate to rise to 0.2
before the end of 2022
and to four 0.4 percent before the end
of 2023
these projections have turned out to be
wide of the mark
the latest published figure for the uk's
rate of inflation in may as measured by
the cpi was 9.1 percent
whilst the mpc increased the uk's bank
rate on the 15th of june to 1.25
second
interest rates around the world have
risen and will rise further in the wake
of the dislocation to supply chains as a
result of the kovid 19
coupled with the destruction to world
energy and foods markets as a
consequence of the ukraine war
contributing to the generation of the
highest rates of inflation in 40 years
and three
in the context of financial markets
where there is such significant
uncertainty therefore the council's
cautious approach to where and how it
funded it holds its funds is well
merited i ask therefore that this report
reviewing the treasury management of the
council's funds over the past year be
received
thank you councillor harvey and i think
you've outlined extremely well just how
much has changed in the short time and
how volatile and
uncertain uh
markets and inflation are at the moment
so unless there are any questions or
input then the recommendation that the
report be received on page one for one
four five our members happy with that
great thank you so moving on uh revenue
budget monitoring once again councillor
harvey thank you leader
the purse of this report is to inform
the cabinet of the revenue picture of
the council's finances to the end of may
2022
i'd like to begin by asking members to
turn to appendix 3 on page 169
this shows that the net budget to be
financed by the council this year is
18.2 million
if we can now turn to appendix 2 on page
167 we can see that the budget for the
whole year is for the total expenditure
of 30.4 billion
and total income from various sources of
13.7 million
the difference between these two numbers
together with the net cost
of benefits of 137 000 pounds represents
the total amount to be funded from
various sources i.e
16.5 million pounds as set out in
appendix 2.
in addition appendix 2 also sets out
that as a result of the covered 19
pandemic the council has received civil
contingencies funding from the
government of almost 1.7 million pounds
the
costs of
594 000 pounds have been incurred in
ways consistent with the government's
intentions leaving a balance of
1.082 million pounds at the end of may
turning to the position at the end of
period 2
we can see that in round terms the
council's expenditure of 7.8 million
pounds was 208 000 pounds more than
budgeted
this reflects the variety of reasons set
out in paragraph three
income received during the period of 4
million pounds was within 120 000 pounds
of the budgeted income for the period
the combination of these results means
that the net cost of services provided
in the first two months of the year was
3.4 million pounds
section 3 of the paper identifies the
principal items of variance from their
budgeted figures during the period april
and may notably the effect of housing
benefits of 154 000 pounds and the net
effect of off-street parking of 141 000
pounds
section 4 provides an early estimate for
the out turn for the year in full at
this stage it is anticipated the
financial years for the sorry that the
financial results for the year will be
very close to the budgeted figures with
an adverse variance of 114 000 pounds
section six of the paper sets out the
council's reserve position which at this
stage is estimated will be reduced by
nine hundred and sixty six thousand
pounds from eight point five million to
7.6 million
importantly this is consistent with the
delivery of the council's current
medium-term financial strategy
appendix 4 sets out the details of the
council's current earmarked reserves
which stand at 11 million pounds and the
purposes for which they are held
subject to any information that mr
burrell might might wish to provide and
to any questions members may now have i
ask that this report is also received
uh any questions or observations members
of cabinet
if not
the recommendations on page one five
nine are we happy with those members of
cabinet
thank you members of cabinet uh
so the final pay premium marathon
counselor harvey is capital budget
monitoring
thank you leader
the purpose of this paper is to keep
members informed of the progress made
over the first two months of the year in
undertaking the council's intended level
of capital expenditures this year
table 2 on page 174 demonstrates the
intention to undertake expenditure of
1.2 million pounds this year excluding
section 106 projects
members will have noticed that appendix
1 reports that 1.5 million pounds has
already been spent in the first two
months of the year
this is an accounting anomaly as a
result of a timing difference across the
year end in relation to the riverside
green project
this will be regularized as a result of
the recommendation concerning slippage
set out in item 8 considered and
accepted earlier in this meeting
appendix 2 on pages 131-135
provides summary information concerning
various projects yet to be funded
through section 106 agreements
of the grand total of 7.6 million pounds
reported on page 187 some 6.6 million
pounds relates to funds identified for
the provision of affordable housing
i asked therefore leader that the
recommendation set out on page 173 that
the report in relation to the two-month
period to the end of may to 2022 be
accepted
thank you councillor harvey are there
any questions or points to raise on this
paper
i'll take that as a resounding no so the
recommendations on page 173
are members of cabinet happy with those
recommendations please can i just point
out there's a typographical error in the
in the recommendation the dates should
have been carried over from a previous
paper of 110
and they should be one to 20 22 23.
[Music]
thank you councillor harvey subject to
councillor harvey's correction are we
happy with the recommendation on page
173
thank you
so
moving swiftly on
uh issues arising from overview and
scrutiny councillor trump i know you've
been inputting on some of the papers uh
uh as we've gone through the meeting are
there any other issues from overview
scrutiny
i think the only one
this is going to be mentioned in
the confidential at um item
17 sorry i can't read my writing so
okay okay
there's nothing else
thank you
thank you councillor crump
so uh
nothing from cabinet committees uh the
cabinet work program on pages 189 to 194
is for noting
uh
there is no urgent business
so matters for decision by the council
uh item 15
um
wells born airfield pages 195 to 196.
uh
where am i
say his name this is under
right councillor pemberton this seems to
be in your name
thank you uh
leader um
members before you is a report um
prepared uh recommending that the
confidential advice prepared by our
solicitors burgess salmon is received
and that
a version 2 or
a second memorandum of understanding
which has also been attached as
confidential papers
is agreed and an authority is given to
the chief executive to to sign
what could be colloquially termed mou2
the background is as members of cabinet
will be aware
this council has a policy position to
preserve and enhance flying functions at
wellsborn manfield airfield
and
has adopted a stance that
as a last resort
should um
it be necessary
this authority will take compulsory
purchase order proceedings against the
owners of wells-born mountfield airfield
to achieve the policy position
should the owners of the airfield's
development aspirations
failed to give life to our policy
position
as part and parcel of that process it's
a very high bar that is set by the
courts to allow for
any public body to cpo private assets
uh and frankly we must be uh in a
position where not only can we
demonstrate a significantly enhanced
public interest for cpo in private land
but that the cpo is very truly the last
resort it follows therefore
that in line with that and with the
general principles of the civil
procedure rules that we engage with and
ensure that proceedings are a last
resort
therefore back in 2019 as part and
parcel of an engagement process
with the landowners we entered into a
memorandum of understanding which
ensured what might be termed
if not a standstill position certainly a
protective position to ensure that
flying functions and aviation was
maintained on the wells born site while
discussions with the landowners and
their representatives took place for the
future of that airfield those
discussions have continued
and the advice is that we should enter a
further
mou
and that is the recommendation before
you i would say to members
it is clearly
if there is any desire to discuss the
confidential advice produced by burgess
salmon we have to do that in a
confidential session
i am of the view and supported by
officers that as the memorandum of
understanding has not yet been signed
off it is in essence a work in progress
and therefore is subject to the same
legal confidentiality and should members
of cabinet wish to discuss
in detail any element of quote mou2
we must move into confidential session
in the absence of wanting to do that i
am seeking uh members agreement to
recommendations one and two on page 195
of your papers thank you
do we need to move into confidential
session
uh judging by
the response from members the answer is
yes
so in that case i am moving
that pursuant to section 100a brackets
four of the local government act 1972 as
amended the public be excluded from the
remaining business of the meeting and
view of the fact that the nature of the
proceedings will be such that if the
public were present there would likely
be disclosure to them of exempt
information on the paragraphs three and
five of part one of schedule 12a to the
said act as amended so we'll just give a
few moments now
oh sorry can i have agreement to that
members have come and agreed
right uh
you